as long as Scotland remains parts of the  Westminster system we have a shared  interest with you in making that system  work better for all of us in making it  work for the many not the few we will  not do any deals that will put the  Tories into power  indeed if there is an anti Tory majority  after me the seventh we will vote to  solve a new Tory government even getting  off the ground but we will then seek to  use our influence positively and  constructively to make a Labour  government bolder and better we will  seek to make common cause and build  alliances with others of like mind  across the UK to deliver the progressive  change that so many want to see and we  will bring to that task eight years  experience of government of successful  effective and stable government